hello everyone we'll be starting the
session in more seven minutes at the
scheduled time
and meanwhile we begin with the workshop
maybe you can
put in the chat box about yourself
your research interests
okay so as we have reached the scheduled
time i think it's the time to begin with
today's workshop
mentoring is described in the literature
as an essential component to career
success productivity and satisfaction
hello and welcome everyone to today's
workshop on project-based bioinformatics
and data science training for faculty
and mentors
this workshop is for faculty seeking to
examine share and strengthen their own
mentoring practices
faculty will learn evidence-based
approaches to research and conceptual
and practical knowledge about various
specialization tracks which include
precision medicine infectious diseases
neurosciences oncology space omics
agriculture and ai based drug discovery
so before we begin with today's workshop
let me introduce us we are a us-based
bioinformatics company who is working
with multiple academic and commercial
collaborators to develop easy to use
analytical tools and our mission is to
make bioinformatics more accessible
the training has been completed by over
15 000 participants from 162 countries
in over 300 workshops and due to this
fast growth our team is working with
local and research coordinators that are
helping refine the local program
logistics and leverage our online
training resources adapting them to the
needs of students and researchers around
the world
i am honored to introduce the founders
and team members of the company
dr alfred tauber comes from a medical
background with an expertise in oncology
immunology and biochemistry of
inflammation and one of his major
projects is the establishment of trouble
bioinformatics research center which has
been at the core of what we do
dr laurent brodsky is the director of
october bioinformatics research center
and is an expert in bioinformatics and
biostatistics
our platform is a result of hard work by
some of the people mentioned here on the
right
julia panna is an expert
bioinformatician avi tatovsky leads the
development of t bioinfo platform dr
mohit mazumdar is an experienced
bioinformatician with multiple
publications in peer-reviewed journal
he has been developing collaborations
with universities as a mentor and
project lead for omix logic training and
research fellowship
dr raghavendra lakshmi narayanan is an
accomplished computational biologist
with an expertise in large scale
analysis of multi or mixed data and data
science methods in precision oncology
and protein dna structural
bioinformatics
ms laura murray educational program
coordinator has a background in
microbiology and bioinformatics and her
focus and areas of expertise are in
metagenomics transcriptomics and
genomics
and my name is sanalika ray and i'm the
community manager responsible for daily
interaction with thousands of users that
are a part of a bioinformatics community
which is managed by buying biotech
so let's discuss about bioinformatics
today what is bioinformatics it is the
development implementation and usage of
methods and software tools for
understanding biological data
bioinformatics has practical
applications in healthcare agriculture
and mitigating climate change
as this field progresses bioinformatics
poses several challenges for both
students trying to learn it and
difficulty trying to teach it
in this presentation i will explain the
current challenges and limitations in
bioinformatics describing how we aim to
address these challenges with the
omixlogic platform
describe bloom's taxonomy and how it can
be used in bioinformatics coursework and
explore the omixlogic program and how it
utilizes bloom's taxonomy in structuring
its course pipelines and projects and
finally describes several outcomes of
the omixlogic program
so what are some of the challenges that
the field of bioinformatics is currently
facing
to begin this field is constantly
growing and developing new tech and
software to improve processing time and
power
the data sets that are analyzed are
usually very large and take immense
amounts of computing power and memory
that many personal computers do not have
also despite being publicly available
data are also usually complex to access
and coding knowledge is usually required
to do so
similarly analysis pipelines and
programs require coding knowledge that
many biologists do not have in a
university setting students have the
opportunity to learn the background
information of designing and
implementing a bioinformatics project
but do not receive practical hands-on
experience with the full workflow due to
the limitations mentioned previously
similarly socialty faces challenges with
being able to cover a diverse range of
topics if they are specialized in a
certain area of bioinformatics or if
they are unfamiliar with bioinformatics
in general
for example a professor whose research
focuses on oncogene expression might not
know much about metagenomics of seawater
to overcome these challenges the
omixlogic platform was developed this
program aims to standardize organize and
systemize bioinformatics training in
order to make these analysis usable for
any biologist or clinician
some problems for standardization
materials for these courses are usually
developed in-house taught sporadically
and are rarely updated
organization because the challenge is to
combine several different topics
together the flow and transitions are
needed to be developed
systemization how can you know that
someone is stuck and needs help or allow
someone to run forward
omixlogic uses standardized modules and
interactive sessions beginning with
mastering terminology and concepts to
implementing these concepts with real
data sets in a project based approach
learning process in order to create a
clear path of skill development
omixlogic employs the bloom's taxonomy
levels of learning this approach starts
with the basics students recall facts
and terminology and are able to repeat
and memorize the material with this
space the learning builds to conceptual
knowledge being able to understand
concepts and apply information to new
situations
the student will then be able to analyze
data by drawing connections and evaluate
when to use certain methods this leads
them to the highest level of learning
the ability to design and create
original work
so how do omix logic resources help in
advancing bioinformatics teaching
omixlogic is a portal for practical and
theoretical learning of bioinformatics
composed of courses designed to take you
through the theoretical knowledge
omixlogic takes a combination of
training modules data analysis tools
curated project datasets and interactive
sessions with mentors to give a student
a clear path the bloom's taxonomy
pyramid no matter what the user's
initial experience with bioinformatics
is omixlogic is a useful tool for
gaining a baseline knowledge of the
theory behind bioinformatics analysis of
large datasets an introduction to basic
coding languages like r and python are
beginning a data analysis project
these six courses were taken from the
core or mixed logic curriculum which is
available online beginning with an
introduction to the application of
bioinformatics and an overview of data
types the student is able to learn
terminology and factual knowledge to
build upon
from there genomics transcriptomics
metagenomics epigenomics and data
science are introduced
each course starts with important terms
and concepts and then introduces case
studies and pipelines related to each
one
this allows the students to gain the
conceptual knowledge in order to begin
their own projects
expanding basic curriculum with projects
bioinformatics methods are best learned
in the context of real case studies
which are prepared by our network of
mentors and collaborators that
illustrate how various bioinformatics
methods and omix data types are used in
current research in medicine
biotechnology agriculture and even
astrobiology
the projects are prepared by taking
publicly available data sets and using
them to explore and understand both the
research challenge and the analysis path
to extract meaningful insights from
complex comics data
the omixlogic platform gives students
options for analyzing a given data set
these data sets and associated
publications can be used in several ways
you can learn bioinformatics without any
coding at all for that in each project
we explain the analysis pipelines on the
user-friendly t by info platform for big
data analysis you can also learn the
scripts behind many of the steps
learning to wrangle clean visualize and
analyze data in popular languages like r
and python in order to create your own
analysis
finally you can hear about the projects
and their research applications in our
mental guided programs where experts
share their experience and support
research projects developed by you
here is an example of the code
independent pipeline
the pipeline builder interface on the t
bioinfo platform is a color coded
pipeline that helps establish a logical
connection between the technical names
of data analysis methods and the logical
steps needed to build the full pipeline
data is put in an input file and then
the analysis can be chosen based off of
the type of research
each analysis is separated into three
colors
blue for pre-processing red for mapping
and green for quantification
each time you click a button a pop-up
will contain additional information
useful for building the pipeline the
ease of the color-coded buttons allows
programs to be run without any coding
knowledge
after using the t-bioinfo platform to
visualize the pipelines and practice
analyzing students are then able to take
their theoretical knowledge remember and
understand levels of dooms and apply
that in a project
apply analyze and evaluate levels of
groups
similarly faculty should be able to
assign the omixlogic program to their
students with the understanding that it
will give them holistic and
comprehensive knowledge of
bioinformatics beginning with bytes and
molecules and onto designing their own
question based project
another goal of the project is for
students to be able to read primary
literature and understand and recreate
the methodology
this leads to the ability to encounter
errors apply theoretical knowledge of
why those errors are occurring and find
a solution
omixlogic employs a hybrid approach
combining learning and research to
ensure that students are building off of
the first level of bloom's taxonomy
omixlogic tracks progress with
activities like pipelines coding and
literature reviews
quizzes on topics k terms and important
questions and covers a broad range of
topics like biomedical research
biotechnology and agriculture
then students are able to continue their
knowledge base with a research
assessment
making sure they are able to understand
methods challenges and results as well
as being able to comprehend primary
research literature
they should also be able to ask
questions based on data exploration
bioinformatics combines life science
terms with data science skills which
allows researchers to answer life
science questions with reproducible data
analysis methods
omixlogic research fellows are able to
ask research questions about any
bioinformatics topic leading to a
diverse range of projects from analyzing
affected biological pathways in multiple
sclerosis to brain metastasis due to
small cell lung cancer
these students are able to apply what
they have learned in the coursework work
with a group of professional mentors and
submit their projects on the portal for
review
students should then be able to reach
the highest level of bloom's taxonomy
create this is achieved through the
creation of their own analysis project
for example semi dolinar an
undergraduate researcher at bachelor
university istanbul turkey who finished
her omixlogic research training was able
to work on the project involving chronic
lymphocytic leukemia cll a type of blood
cancer that has a very heterogeneous
biological background
and diverse treatment strategies here at
first she elucidated 870 significantly
differentially expressed protein coding
genes that were involved in the
biogenesis and processing of rna
consequently these findings led our
study to investigate non-coding rna
33 long non-coding rnas were found to be
significantly differentially expressed
among two conditions based on
differential gene expression analysis
one final example of a learning outcome
of the onyx logic program
is this project presentation for a
project done in collaboration between
nagochi memorial institute for medical
research and biotech
here is our team at pine biotech who
were involved with the project dr mohit
mazumdak dr harpreet kaur as well as our
collaborators at university of khana dr
anita gansha and dr benedict tamensa
this poster was on plasmodium falciparum
apical membrane antigen
robbery neck protein two binding which
is a critical interaction for plasmodium
falciparum mirazoid invasion of
human-host red blood cells
several proposed malaria vaccine
candidates designed to prevent such
binding and limit neurozoid entry have
been studied with variable success at
in-vitro and early clinical trial stages
by performing haplotype network analysis
of genomic sequencing data from sites
with variable infection rates comparing
our data with malaria gen repository
from another region in ghana and mapping
of genomic variants onto the protein
structures we arrive at preliminary
conclusions about local variation and
immunogenic epitope affecting variance
for consideration
in this poster we share preliminary
findings that suggest that such genomic
data can be used to develop a local
strategy for efficacious vaccine design
against plasmodium falciparum blood
stage infection in ghana and surrounding
regions
omixlogic is proud to collaborate with
diverse programs for example neby the
national association of idea principal
investigators we also work with over 15
000 students at community colleges like
glendale community college top-tier
universities like georgetown university
as well as 20 universities around the
world
now to talk about the programs in more
detail i would like to pass on the stage
to dr mohit mazumdar over to user
thank you sanatika just a second please
thank you
and hello everyone it's uh it's really
nice to see you all today and
to start with i will just like to tell
you that pine biotic was founded by a
team of biotechnologists biologists
clinicians mathematicians and computer
scientists that agreed on the critical
role big data will play in biomedical
research biotechnology and agriculture
so one of the reasons that we are
meeting uh in together uh today is that
we all agree to the fact that uh we we
know that big data is playing a critical
role and bioinformatics has changed and
evolved from a discipline that was not
so much of
um utilized by the universities or by
organizations however its growth has
tremendously uh changed the paradigm
because it's application in biomedical
research so with growing data
availability and its heterogeneity and
complexity it is not sufficient to
design innovative algorithms to detect
pattern so to go from pattern to inside
people especially biologists clinicians
students technicians they need to be
empowered to work with data
independently and that's why our
founding team united behind the vision
to simplify and uh to simplify
bioinformatics that is one of the key
reasons that uh we have showcased you
the the designs and other on the portal
and the platform
so by offering hands-on learning with
really user-friendly analytical
solutions we envision more people will
be equipped for data-driven reproducible
research which solves biomedical
problems but problems in biotechnology
and aggro technology
and all of that
so um one of the key reasons uh we
believe in this is because uh the data
that has been growing tremendously is
not being utilized by the
uh by the faculty by the clinicians
because of lack of several of those
elements that just sunalika discussed
about so our team at pine biotech
specializes in bioinformatics and big
data
project driven curriculum
that integrates into the university
curricula helping students take
advantage of the resources
working with industry experts to develop
cutting-edge research projects and data
data analysis skill sets so this
collaborative
specialization training helps prepare
the student and researchers for
industrial and academic jobs as well as
internship opportunities so during this
collaboration process our team uh here
at pinewood tech share case studies
effective strategies that have been used
by the universities
for uh with our partner universities in
the us in africa and in india to
introduce bioinformatics to
non-bioinformaticians and
non-engineering students and also to
support research projects from faculty
and students uh through this research
fellowship program so today i'm going to
show you glimpses of some of those uh
some of those achievements with
universities and students who were able
to
come out from this uh training and uh
get
opportunities but also a pathway which
we have created utilizing these
resources uh to overcome these
challenges and create an uh scientific
ecosystem and a omics logic community
that actually helps each other and
facilitate all of this together
so uh
over the last few years our team
as a team we have been able to help our
partnering universities and other
collaborators by working together taking
students
to the classroom to the real world
application from their classroom to the
real world application uh from
learning about the basic coursework and
also applying the translational research
by using data science and biotechnology
uh so some of our collaborators as as
already mentioned
are from different universities across
the globe so developed these courseworks
have been developed and reviewed uh in
collaboration with universities where
there are leading experts in
bioinformatics
omics logic in itself is a comprehensive
and a flexible program which enables
helps
faculty to
design
the program according to their need and
also help students faculty and industry
to succeed in this age of data so the
program will help you learn what you
need to know about
advanced scientific research
and also participate in the future of
biomedicine
learn how to mine high throughput data
and discover new insights with exercises
in r or python with coding on the t by
info platform so uh these data types
that sunalika was just mentioning so the
basic coursework that we have prepared
understanding that uh our students are
from all around the globe coming from
different
uh educational background we have
students from africa we have students
from india we have students from top
universities in india in africa and also
in the us and we also have students
coming from a background uh where the
education is not comparable with the top
universities so we have prepared the
basic coursework uh that is designed for
students who can who do not have a
background in bioinformatics and uh you
know they are they many times they do
not even have a very good background in
biology so those students who wants to
start from the very beginning very
basics and are eager to learn about data
data analysis uh so we cover topics such
as genomics transcriptomics metagenomics
and their analysis we include in these
sessions at the introductory level about
the statistical analysis methods
visualizations and introduction to all
the popular machine learning methods for
omics data analysis so students uh used
to get to learn from uh
not only up by learning about the
technology or the
tools or the algorithms but also they
will learn how to apply these algorithms
to real data sets and how do we get to
those real data sets that's a very good
question thinking from a pi perspective
from a principal investigator
perspective or from a faculty
perspective is that how do we utilize
the public data repositories and
understand the various file formats in
bioinformatics for storing analyzing and
effective processing of this different
types of data types so the first uh
step towards this is the basic
introductory course work that we have
prepared and there are detailed uh
curriculums
for all of these data types that we go
through in our own mixed large programs
that we go through with our university
partners that i could quickly show you
uh using the web browser so let me go to
the to the web browser where we have uh
where i can show you that what we are
talking about and where this is all uh
is available so a couple of resources
think of it as two
two repositories two repositories that
we are using plus a lot of open source
uh open source uh tools and resources so
these two repositories for example this
is the portal omixlogic learn portal
where we have the courses where we have
the virtual classroom
where we have the student tracking
system where we have the research
projects all of the documentation is
available here
and the tutorials as well so this
omixlogic portal is a place for faculty
to choose
what kind of specialization they would
want to work on or they would want to
teach and if they are all if you are
already teaching a specific
specialization our team is capable of
integrating the coursework and adding
projects related to your publication for
the specialization so we can discuss
that those things over a call if you're
interested in such uh collaboration
however to utilize this from uh for
student uh learning for to utilize this
as a course work for many uh who could
uh you know really benefit from the uh
basic introduction to bioinformatics
basic introduction to ngs bioinformatics
computational biology and data science
so i think it is a lot of it it has a
lot of value for students who are
graduating now who are uh
like who
want to work on the data analysis aspect
in biomedical research so uh this is one
resource that we will go through in
detail but as as you can see there are
different tabs here from courses
programs projects research that you can
explore you can start by creating a free
login so when i create click here you
the first step that it asked me is to
create a free login i can use my social
media handles i can use my own gmail
password and
i can log in so this is very simple um
for anyone to start with
any student any faculty to take a look
at and then then the courses so these
are asynchronous courses that we are
going to discuss and along with this
asynchronous courses uh the practical
sessions the coding and also the expert
sessions and also the industry sessions
all of this
creates this amazing ecosystem for a
student to learn about not only to learn
about a specific subject but to
understand that what are the application
where the industry is going with it and
where should i take what are the
different steps that one should take to
excel in some of these
areas and to contribute so
uh going back uh we have these two
resources as i was telling you one of
these resources is the learn enormous
logic another resource is the robot
bioinformatics research platform where
which is the workbench where you can
design all these different experiments
and analyze the data and that too on a
cloud so one of the biggest advantage is
the infrastructure that it provides you
usually to crunch big data you would
require a high-end server and a lot of
investment from the university to be to
maintain that server so one of the
biggest advantages of the t-band
platform is that uh the reproducibility
and you can be taking uh different ways
to analyze one kind of data and also to
be able to do this on cloud from your
own laptop from a laptop with basic
minimum requirement uh so those are some
of the things that one could be able to
one one could
use with uh all these resources that we
are offering
through the
collaborative programs now along with
these two resources i wanted to take you
to the uh to the omixlogi program page
so as i was telling you that we have
these different curriculums where we are
so here it is so let me share this link
with you so this is omix logic programs
and these are the programs that we are
pilot that we are doing with our partner
universities uh and
thousands of students are going through
this course work so what is these the
these different different courseworks
that we have put together so for example
introduction to bioinformatics in uh
genomics omix logic genomics data
analysis here you have data science and
you here you have genomic metagenomics
so when you click on the link
uh you'll be redirected to a page where
the entire curriculum of this program is
available so you will be able to see uh
the uh the webinars that we did with for
this program which actually explains
this in a very detailed manner but you
can also take a look at the curriculum
here itself to learn the about the
different topics that would be covered
that are usually covered in these
programs that will help you to work on
applying these techniques to different
type of data assets and also the
asynchronous course work and the
tutorials that are available with it so
it encompasses live sessions uh
tutorials and also um the topics that we
are covering with project examples so we
are working on data and we are
understanding about these different
topics and we are doing coding sessions
along with that and then we are going
through the case studies so this is a
comprehensive three-month curriculum
this curriculum is also available in one
month uh one month of version uh where
we are going through some of the
important topics and many of these are
done through the asynchronous material
which is available on the learnomics
logic as you have seen so these
hyperlink these are hyperlinked to these
lessons when i when you click you you
you can go to you will go to the direct
directly to that lesson and uh you need
to
have a login for that and uh i hope that
you all are creating a login for
yourself to explore some of these
amazing resources
that could enable us to provide uh
proper uh resources for the student
community uh that we are connected with
so as i was telling you that these
resources are linked to get linked to
the link to the sessions so any faculty
who is teaching this course can utilize
all of this material and can also
untrack student progress so this is uh
similarly we have uh meta genomics
genomics very detailed curriculums uh
where the focus is about you know
learning about specific uh type of
analysis and also uh doing uh uh and
learning about uh different types of an
application for example in the case of
genomics what we are trying to learn is
about specific application of where this
genomic data can help us find variants
and all of that so these programs are
designed with specific application
based outcomes and also project
proposals if a researcher is thinking
about applying this type of analysis to
the available data sets so that's how
these basic programs are put together so
going back to my presentation so we have
this basic coursework which is also like
available for everyone like connected to
a university through a partnership
program so if we have a mou in place
with the university and if we have a
partnership together then we have a
partnership program for students where
the basic coursework is is freely
available for students to complete and
then choose whether they would want to
go for advanced analysis and choose for
mentorships and so henceforth where
they'll have to pay the fee but however
for basic coursework for partner
universities we have uh prepared a
program which is uh which is to help
them go through very basics of
bioinformatics learn about these
different technologies and also uh get
an interest of what is going on in the
scientific community to be able to uh
take proper decisions for their
educational um career for the career and
also for their education
going for to do a masters or a phd what
to choose and all those answering all
those questions so
uh as i was telling you that this entire
process is tracked so as a mentor if you
have students who are going through this
course work you will be able to see
their progress you will be able to see
what their achievements are so uh that
is done through the omics logic profile
so once a profile helps us to learn
about each other and also to learn
about what we are doing in terms of big
data research coding where am i with my
courses where am i with my certification
where am i within the program that how
many suggestions i have completed what
is left all those can be tracked through
your profile that you create once you
create your free login so uh similarly
when you join a program so as i was
telling you that introduction to
bioinformatics uh similarly
transcriptomics infectious disease you
just join a program you get a badge for
that program and you get a subscription
to get access to all of those so this
entire process is tracked through point
systems system so when you do something
uh when you complete a course when you
run a pipeline when you complete the
lesson when you update your profile you
get achievement points so these
achievement points accumulate and let us
know about your level of expertise so as
a mentor you can see the student and see
that their activities and the points
they can they have accumulated and
through this you can categorize students
amongst different categories based on
their points that they have accumulated
throughout their experience throughout
the time the program so that uh you so
that we can identify those students who
would be eligible to work on a really
good question on a research project
utilizing these technologies utilizing
these resources
so that's how programs are structured
and in programs you will find
courseworks coursework zoom link all of
this in a single interface where
on the omixlogic
learn program uh
program
tab so gaining certification getting
featured and most importantly it helps
us to track the progress of every
individual so uh all of this process is
helpful a scheduled program so when we
are doing a scheduled program for
example in in this example you can see
we started a program from 22nd june to
31st august where we have a lot of live
sessions where we have these
asynchronous material where we have a
communication channel with the student
so a scheduled program on learn uh
provides an interface for the
participant and the mentor to access the
resources at one place get information
about the upcoming schedule online or
on-site sessions and the links
associated with that session that
includes uh asynchronous courses big
data pipelines data sets from ncbi or a
publication or references etc
so this entire pipeline so many students
uh in our
experience need a soft landing into this
field of bioinformatics getting started
getting introduced to the application of
bioinformatics through projects and
examples and gain access to a community
with mentorship guidance and structure
so uh independent virtual learning with
our online data science courses in
person bioinformatics workshop with
practical exp examples to take straight
from the classroom to the bench
university college accreditation and
certification is also available with our
partner universities so from basic
learning from step one to learning uh
through the data sets and through
project examples those examples could be
from precision medicine those examples
could be from oncology immunology
neuroscience infectious diseases and
many other life scientific life science
uh
fields where this data is being
generated so advanced training is about
that and then specialization is where
you start uh
start developing an
interest about a specific area of
research and you would want to work on
that area of research so that step is
then uh the project and then the
showcase part is where you have an
opportunity to showcase your uh to
showcase the work that you did for
recognition to the scientific community
through symposium through uh the the
platform that uh the international
community provides and also what uh
platform that we provide so this entire
process like from uh you know training
for to the asynchronous coursework is
actually structured so each module uh
within these uh training modules so in
transcriptomics you see uh
we have a coursework detailed post book
about transcriptomics you saw that we
have a detailed coursework in
metagenomics similarly you saw this data
science so all of these are structured
and designed using five elements so
these five elements are rational and
objective
engaging activities
then uh multimedia and tutorials then
practical application and then uh the
test so quantification and tests so
these elements are consistent throughout
all the coursework that we have put
together so in each coursework with
rational and objective to set
expectations for the learning relevant
technology is listed and placed into the
biological context throughout the lesson
so different type of data data types are
are presented linked to linked those to
the logic behind each of the analysis
methods that are thoroughly described
when needed so each course contains
engagement engaging activities to make
the material easier to read through and
remember so these concept these include
concept mapping quiz uh question
analysis as well as extensive glossary
of to conceptualize and conceptualize
complex terminologies and functional
linkages that helps associate
bioinformatics analysis workflow and
their function so courses are enriched
in a lot of video and multimedia insert
that helps explain uh
some of the topics with ease due to the
uh visual interface finally the course
material uh and the
is reviewed in module quizzes and tests
these are timed and tied in in with the
overall within the overall student
progress so during the course student
and the faculty will be able to see how
they made make progress throughout the
courses complete practical assignments
and performances in the quizzes so this
data is crunched to provide basis for
certification at the end of the journey
so as i was telling you that we have a
lot of project examples so these project
examples are from well-digested
publications uh
highly peer-reviewed publications
and uh our team is capable of taking
publications so for example if a faculty
if if i have a publication and it in
involves bioinformatics methods and i
would want to teach
using that publication to my class so
our team is capable of converting those
publications into these research
projects that could be integrated into
the curriculum utilizing the the server
or utilizing some of the tools that
could be uh helpful in uh developing a
project for educational purpose so these
are educational projects about different
topics from precision medicine to
infectious diseases to population health
to biotechnology and agriculture space
and astrobiology so these are available
on omix logic learn for students to take
that step two so the step one is to
learn about the very basics develop
understanding about each of this uh each
of these um keywords first and then
understand that how the data analysis is
done and using some of the example data
assets and then go to some advanced data
sets
and develop some specialization in some
of these areas so followed by that we
have a group of mentors who are
available to help students progress
through these different steps
of
taking from
basic learning to learning about how do
you access all of these resources and
then how do you manage your time and
then what is the outcome that you are
actually going to get based on your
efforts so all of these are done through
uh through our support team and also
through our mentors and through all
these resources that i've showed you
just now so uh doing these basic
coursework is very important for anyone
to do go for specialization so in
specialization we also have like very
specialized courseworks coursework which
is designed for groups such as
the namuchi group that you saw so the
naguchi group is have an infectious
disease
agenda they are working on different
infectious diseases and they want to
incorporate a lot of omics research into
that uh into their into their
into their research so we collaborated
with them first for this infectious
disease program where we help the
student and the phd students and also
master students to uh to in incorporate
uh high-end bioinformatics to their
studies so that the uh the study is more
robust and more complete with uh taking
advantage of big data and the data that
is available
on public repositories and the data they
have generated so obviously the impact
of that study is going to enhance a lot
and you kind of integrate and understand
different types of uh
data to
think about a system biology or a
holistic approach for a certain problem
so that is something for specialization
coursework curriculum that we have and
uh my team is here on uh
so they will be able to help share about
the specialization course tracks and uh
the suggestions we have designed and the
curriculums that we have designed for
such posts work so similarly we have
course work on precision medicine we
have course work on uh we have we have
project work on omix and agribiology and
we
will be happy to collaborate with some
of the agricultural institute and uh
and complete this
specialization track uh similarly we
recently started omix space omix and
there will be a lot of a lot of experts
from the industry and from the academic
areas coming and talking about space
omics and also helping
students learn about the area where this
space where space omix is
is utilized so it's a space comics is
dedicated to the study of homies data to
study molecular mechanisms affected by
space travel and
which is critical for astronomers
astronauts health so uh
along with that along with not just
omics but also um
kami informatics and drug discovery we
are going to uh show we are going to
come up with this summer program
we're in in april where we are going to
discuss the application of uh game
informatics and drug discovery and also
understand from a
standpoint of how do you interpret and
analyze three-dimensional structure
three-dimensional data from biomedical
uh research from uh from the public
repository in similar lines to what we
are doing with uh with our other data
types so combining all of this uh now
just i'll just want to take you
back there how do you know which program
is coming when so we have a schedule uh
page
so it's an event page that we have put
together so i'll uh our team will be
sharing this page so in this page you
will see that the number of events that
we are doing in march we did a lot of
events including this one uh the faculty
mentor workshop we have the mix logic
symposium coming up and also in march uh
we uh we are going to conclude with uh
post representation and all of that for
a student in april we have these
programs coming up introduction to
bioinformatics chem informatics so you
can check this out we keep on updating
this page
to see
the training programs that we have
planned throughout the summer many of
these programs will be available so uh
along with these training programs uh
the component of doing a research work
or project work is something that i
wanted to cover in this presentation so
uh as as as
we are discussing about these different
type of technologies followed by these
technologies uh how do we apply these
technologies on a real data set and real
problem
so uh we have this program called
research fellowship or indus and
industry internship so a research
fellowship is where you are trying to
work on your on a research problem where
the faculties are also um
providing us with their research problem
what uh what their students could work
on uh in the in a university system so
we recently collaborated with uh amit
university uh where we collaborated
for
faculty development and also we
collaborated for research projects and
training of students and
working with
a group of students who would work on
faculty projects and develop those
faculty projects for commercialization
for also um
for also like grant and publications and
all of that so through the internship
program uh with the faculty of a
university uh this is possible and that
is what we have created uh for
universities as a program where we are
taking this step one step two step three
step four uh from a cohort uh where we
are starting a program uh about the
partnership program which is just about
the basic
which is free and then the hands-on and
the guided programs where you have all
these examples and all these uh all
these data sets to explore and develop
those those skill sets to be able to
work on a research project so the to be
able to work on a research project it's
called the summer research fellowship
the summer research fellowship is coming
up in this summer but this research
fellowship program is available to
students to develop projects on on of
their own uh and uh using these all
these types of uh analysis methods so
after completing the training student
can develop independent project
proposals identify existing group
projects on or collaborate and find
internship around the omics logic cohort
so along with the faculty projects that
the faculty can propose uh in
collaboration with the pine biotech
mentors uh there are other opportunities
for students as well
so bioinformatics does play a critical
role in modern drug discovery so we are
working on projects such as drug
repurposing biomarker screening and
design of personalized treatment regimes
so as a result many industry and
research labs are seeking out experts
that are knowledgeable in homeless data
processing analysis and integration some
of these skill sets are really really
important for students who are seeking
uh jobs and internships and career in
this a in this field so we have already
discussed some of these outcomes based
on the number of hours that the students
are able to give the number of hours
that a trainer is able to give and also
like uh the time uh timeline of the
internships so this internship program
and also like designing a bioinformatics
project we have already have the
coursework for anyone to learn about
these different steps uh after learning
about the coursework like how do we do
look for research topics we have
recorded videos for all of these steps
uh and also uh data sets uh that we have
uh working on with different students
and are published and showcased in
different poster competitions in in
around the globe
and getting recognition so for students
it's a great opportunity because not
only through linkedin but also through
different uh
different challenges different
symposiums different workshops uh
getting recognition and winning
those events and also getting uh
positions uh abroad which are fully
funded so these are some of the
opportunities that we saw with uh some
of the students such as ujja she is
doing a fully funded phd based on the
research she did and proposed uh in
germany now after finishing her masters
similarly the lara is working who worked
on a uh space owings project were able
to publish this project and now working
on uh as a space for mix mentor and uh
we also have high school students who've
been able to do the same using some of
these automatic resources and also
coming up with projects that they
thought could be helpful as a citizen
scientist
providing them with the right resources
we saw that there is a huge interest in
high school students and uh huge
potential as well
so uh these courses as i said like are
uh are
decided on the basis of the interest of
the faculty and also the administration
some universities are looking for
courses in
data science and machine learning and
how do you apply and some some of the
universities are looking at very
specialized courses and all of them do
begin with the basic basic course work
that is to integrate and bridge the gap
that we see in bioinformatics curriculum
that has been taught for years and years
where we are trying to go through the uh
go through the content which is rapidly
changing and evolving in this period in
this era so that is one of the reasons
that we have come up with all of these
curriculums so that it integrates with
the university curriculum and so that
students get an opportunity to learn
about the scientific research that is
ongoing and get relevant opportunity in
the industry
so uh obviously to learn about all of
this you need to learn and start at an
early stage that helps you develop all
these skill sets and understand about
this different type of data and also to
be able to come up with a project with
uh with good outcomes so to help with
that this we not only have academic
christians but also industry leaders uh
who come up who comes uh or time to time
and help students with job opportunities
and also career guidance so um there are
also opportunities for students to
become campus ambassadors and uh
represent these uh opportunities to
another group of students so uh uh with
this i would like to
i would like to ask uh if there are any
questions that uh if if you think that
any of this is interesting and i would
be really uh appreciate i would really
appreciate if there's any feedback uh
from
from the from the participants
excuse me sir
excuse me
may i know what's the difference between
computation tool and the bioinformatics
tool
i don't understand the difference
difference between computational tool
and
bioinformatics tool
so a computational tool which uh which a
computational tool can be any tool that
uses computational uh power to help in
some sort of to analysis so a
computational tool that you are using
could be a word processor is a
computational tool but when we are
talking in the context of bioinformatics
then we are talking about a tool that
can analyze biological data a tool that
can help in
the biological data so the kind of data
changes and obviously with that the
specialization changes and so some of
these computational tools which are used
for day-to-day life and for other
activities uh varies from the
biotechnology or bioinformatics tool
that is developed by the scientific
community who are working for age days
now
okay thank you sir
thank you sir
okay thank you
and dr alan and if there are any more
questions i will be happy to answer
and uh uh some of the resources and i'm
going to i'm going to go back to some of
the pages
that are we have prepared so as i saw as
i showed you already so this is the
research collaborative uh omixlogic
page for research projects that we have
prepared this has all the links and
pipelines that we have created for the
universities so our collaborative
universities such as amity university
noida what we have been able to do is
that we have created a pipeline starting
from a basic training getting registered
to completing the basic modules that i
showed you completing the intermediate
course work and then certification and
giving a qualification examination and
then doing the research fellowship and
getting some of these
outcomes so you can see that there are
many students who've been able to
complete and go through this entire
funnel and pipeline and come up with
research projects which we were able to
publish on a portal and also elsewhere
so this entire journey starts with the
starts with collaboration with
universities and also we get to uh visit
the universities meet them in person
students and help so similarly from the
university
there's an administrator there's a
professor this student who helps in
coordinating all of that and
collaborating for uh for some of these
outcomes that we achieve from these
these collaborations so this is about
the university who are utilizing our
programs and also for uh people who are
interested in research uh different type
of research we have this page called uh
research topics so here what we have
done is what we have put together is
like what kind of research that you can
do for infectious disease bioinformatics
so some of these are listed out not all
of them obviously but uh we have put
together a different omics
application and also for different areas
of research that we are working with our
students that we are working with some
of the faculties are brought together
here and with some examples obviously
and with some sessions from experts that
uh that have helped uh students to learn
about these uh different technologies so
this is another page that i wanted to
show you all uh and then we have this uh
for those who would want to uh not do it
themselves but uh provide give it uh to
the experts to do the some of the work
so if you want to integrate omix data
analysis into your own research you can
collaborate through uh our server
services so you can
you can let us do
the work that you would want in your
publication or in your research project
and we have this omix logic service for
that where we have licensing for
different types of research that you
would want to do which is a monthly
license and also we have these different
uh sample based analysis uh options that
are available which are as a service
that you can take and we will provide
you with the report and all the details
of
that with all the details of analysis
that we do for a specific project so
this this works out when uh before that
we have several discussion and we
finalize and we scope the uh the scope
the
uh project and the objectives so then we
have the kami informatics program the
the uh
topics you can take
and the curriculum you can take a look
here it's a basic program on chemi
informatics and uh structural biology
following following with that we will
have another program which will be more
about ai machine learning and using
structure biology for uh drug discovery
uh to a more detailed uh
aspect in the in the late summer and
then i wanted to also show you i've
already shown you this and
the courses and the research symposium
so we have an amazing event coming up
and i really appreciate it if uh many of
you could join this event so there are a
lot of sessions that would be uh about
different technologies and what we've
been able to work and with different uh
partners so
we have a session about asia and then we
have sessions from university partners
in india and also we have session about
the research fellowship program and also
poster competition and then we have uh
the african uh
uh participants are going to talk about
the programs there and the university in
africa and the uh and the industry in
africa talking about the challenges and
also the ongoing work in bioinformatics
in africa then we have the u.s panel
starting with mr lebrotsky our ceo and
then we have uh uh sessions from experts
uh from the u.s
from reputed universities such as
georgetown university and professor
sonavasudevan then google talking about
their strategic programs and
cloud technology and then we have
[Music]
then we have dr adelaide rhodes where
she will be talking about bioinformatics
as a career option and addressing all of
those so many questions could be
answered we have a panel for latin
america followed by the there will be a
discussion then on the day two we have
this uh we have the industry from india
we have the industry from uh from europe
uh we have the the uh
we have uh in from the us we are talking
about lab and future and women in stem
from pistol alliance where there's a
group of
group of
organizations uh working on different
aspects then we have a specialized
session by tower research in in banff
tower bioinformatics research center
where these uh experts are going to come
and talk about very specific topics
uh covering single cell transcriptomics
data analysis and then uh
how do we work with uh and customize
pipelines and then there are 16s rrna
meta taxonomy and then many for learning
so it will be an enthrilling experience
for all of us who will be attending the
session and i'll be really glad if you
can also make it it's a free for
listener and it also gives an
opportunity for students to be a part of
this and also uh get certification uh at
the end of this so we have space omix as
i was telling you that a lot of experts
coming from nasa and elsewhere to talk
about uh space omix and also there will
be price uh distribution ceremony for
students who get
the
prizes for best poster and then we have
the u.s panel discussion where we were
discussing about the nippy national
association of idea principal
investigators and the nih grants and all
of the work that is going on
to help uh
to help integrate data science and
bioinformatics in u.s through the nih
grants so this will be a great
experience so i would encourage all of
you to join so this is it from my part
of the presentation i hope that this has
been useful for many of you who have
joined and please feel free to reach out
to us
for any sort of uh
queries any sort of questions or any
anything related to
anything
curriculums training and uh
and also faculty research thank you so
much
so if there are no more questions we
will conclude this session and we will
be hoping you in the symposium or the
upcoming live sessions that we are going
to do uh in the future thank you so much
and have a great day
take care bye